the jogan experience I thought when she
got in trouble it would just just blow a
hole through everything come on I
thought when she they were coming after
her for you think you're going to get a
for what for being a diva like what was
the worst thing she did I thought it was
like it would put an end like d you
see we just enjoy do anything yeah she's
inoc also for real I know it's like free
lizo
what was her accusations like she made a
performer shove banana [__] sh [__]
baller [__] dude her
rules I've seen her puts on a good
concert she's good I've seen I though
although I will say I was actually
pissed when they made her twerk with I
think it was James Madison's
flute piss me off why such a [__] I
kind of like it I think it symbolizes
the time we're living in I think it does
do it I think the time sucks [__] it's
maybe but maybe not it depends on your
perspective it's the most fun time to be
alive all right here's here's genuinely
it's like I get it I genuinely don't
care about that guy's [__] flute [__]
him about you like married but I know
why they're celebrating it right they're
like yeah yeah in your [__] face and
it's like come on dude the guy founded
America yeah yeah what you do wrong
I know they don't give a [__] about
history
right and by they I mean white liberals
she play a 200y old flute
Jesus that was
emic that yeah I guess I don't give a
[__] about it zero problem with
that she was she wasn't playing it like
recklessly she's the only she twerk you
play which is fine imagine the street
cred you would get if you spiked it and
said [__] white
supremacy that would kill ja oh my God
that would be the most polarizing moment
in human history that like wow I take
back like what the [__] for the record I
take back my opinion from one minute ago
I still think I get the thing that does
suck about it though is them covering it
that's the problem they're covering it
because they want you to be mad she
might have been doing it because like oh
I'm playing one of the presidents that's
what they did dis dismiss
was like you play the flute you're a
major performer we want you to play the
flute so she did
itle her butt a little is that the
biggest problem we have why there's
[__] drone bombings in Yemen and
invasion of Ukraine and like what who
gives a [__] but that's where it gets
confusing she did what she does she did
first of all she did it in her underwear
yeah yeah costume I mean look look how
she's dressed go back to that please go
please please the wiggling of the
buttcks I take it back if I me imagine
if they have approved that costume so
they approve this costume right I take
it all back got Shadow she's going to
run run for Senate no I'm back I hate it
this costume the we're all over the
place with this can I hear how good she
played it yeah she's a good flautist she
is
flout she does love flute keep that in
mind
it would be funny if they were like this
is actually a Native American flute this
is her instrument oh take it allk now
take it back now I'm back in take it
back I think it actually rules she her
one instrument is the flute and she's
like I'm playing a president's my
instrument she did it well and so she
[__] moved her body a little bites a
[__] that's fine I agree with that Joe
what does it say what does say what is
it while racist play dog whistles what
is the problem
what people are having with lizo has
nothing to do with the
flute has everything to do with the fact
that she's a black woman playing flu
that belong to a slave owner oh [__] Rex
H dude want to be a downer you any
positive stories
BR get angry about here's my take if
you're getting mad at Liz if you're a
right-wing conservative person and you
get mad at lizo playing the flute like
that that's leftwing you're the left
wing people are mad he he's mad
at people are mad that she played that
the rightwing people this why he's
saying dog whistles listen he's saying
that the rightwing people are mad he's
saying the right people are mad because
she's playing the flute of a slave owner
exactly yes that's what wouldn't
leftwing be mad no no play the
instrument of
the you could go that way too because
the rightwing people are mad that she is
being disrespectful the angel again the
right-wing people are being mad Hari
Angel
salar the Jews killed Jesus and an
angel the rightwing people are mad
because lizo is supposedly being
disrespectful to historical flute but
clearly she's not being disrespectful at
all in fact she's the flute she's
playing the flute it's got to be holding
it very carefully she's playing it well
it's got to be left people mad but she's
no it's rightwing people but she's being
lizo while she's doing it like if going
to hire lizo to do it what do you want
her to do she's going to do what lizo
does it's like R the national anthem I'm
going to make
[Music]
J there was also that show that she had
F dancer on tour and they their ankles
couldn't sustain it like you're on tour
now a show D were on tour these ladies
were dancing on tour wasn't there like
some kind of crazy thing my 600 lb life
it was like a lot no it was like these
big girls that were dancing on tour D
blowing out mcl's and well that that
just looks like an airport at that big
dog backp like these are Big Girls this
just looks like uh look at the [__]
Saturday night at so get out there and
just you guys see the guy on the left
whoa what's going is that a guy is this
the California Panthers a [__] H
Foley dude Jesus Christ Sumo Team zic Ed
oh my
God
she's a fun lady yeah yeah she's a fun
lady we got to get her on here no no I I
highly doubt she'd be interested in that
I think she would she might stop herself
but she would be interested because she
[__] rules well listen man like you
watch all that that's fun that's all fun
to me I don't have any problem with the
way she played that flute she was really
good at it good flute who else is doing
Rock flute it went to the 70s nothing
until today they also must have like
green L it like it's not like it was her
idea it was the gay they were saying it
was [__] liberal ass liberals
Smithsonian liberal ass Smithsonian so
they wanted it to happen because they
wanted her to play the flute of a slave
owner is that really no a president yes
they did Aid they wanted to be like we
did
it and then uh but kind of didn't they
do it isn't that like okay to celebrate
like isn't it I mean isn't that a weird
thing I know I agree it is a weird thing
I mean it it's kind of pretty badass
that like imag being most famous black
artist is playing a is playing a flute
of a guy who owns slaves imagine being
at the that's the most American thing
possible it's pretty [__] America
yeah very imagine being at the concert
and this guy she's playing a [__]
president's flute and you're the
audience go I don't know how I feel
about this well nobody in thead going
this rules but then I saw it on Twitter
and I had a couple drinks and I was
looking at it and I was going I don't
know how I feel about at the show it
would have been like this is I was at
the show where she played the [__]
president's flute yeah
that is cool they're not doing that in
Germany yeah they're not doing in
Germany they're not playing
uh harmonica it really all
depends right he's just doing the
[__] Imperial March on Monica I will
say if if some Jew ripped a [__]
electric guitar that owned that Hitler
owned it would be it would be cool
Monica
Lewinsky like if somebody let Paul
McCartney play Napoleon's piano yeah
that would be pretty [__] dope to
watch wait did he attack us Napoleon I
don't think he ever touched America took
over America they took American Youth
that's right yeah they ruined it well
they stole black rock and roll and then
they came over here and corrupted our
[__] oh the
British